نحن في هذه اللحظات في منطقه الحي السعودي
غربي مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه هذه
المنطقه باتت ماوى لعشرات الاف الاسره
الفلسطينيه النازحه فرارا من نيران الحرب
الاسرائيليه سواء في خان يونس او في
المنطقه الوسطى او مدينه غزه هنا عائلات
تفترش الطرقات ولم تجد لها اي ماويه حتى
يعني خيام لا تتوفر لهؤلاء النازحين هذهه
سيده فلسطينيه وجدت هذه الحافله مع اسرتها
وربما لم تجد اي ماوى اخر وجلست هنا
رغما عنها حجه الله يعطيك العافيه بدايه
من وين جيتوا انتم والله احنا جينا من
خنون سنا من 5 12 وحين واحنا قاعدين هنا
ماويين في بص الزلمه وهالحين الزلمه
بقولنا اطلعوا ما فيش لكم ماوه بنام زي ما
انت شايف هي الماوه والله ابني عارف من
كثر اله وهو نايم في هذه النتفه انه ساقف
لا في ضو لا في فريش ولا في حاجه وهذا
احنا في الشارع ايش نسوي لك
احنا كمان بنطالب نروح يردونا لو دورنا
انقصف بدنا نقعد فيقيم ونقعد في دورنا كل
منطقه نسير بها نجد مثالا لهذه العائلات
التي باتت بلا ماوى وهذه اسره فلسطينيه
ربما نزحت بطبيعه الحال من اكثر من منطقه
على مستوى قطاع غزه نجري هنا لقاء مع احدى
السيدات اللواتي يتواجدن هنا في هذا
المكان الله يعطيكم العافيه بدايه والحمد
لله على السلامه الله يسلمك الله يعطيك
الف عافيه من وين جيت انت وين وين كنتم شو
اللي صار معكم احنا بالاصل والله من غزه
الصبره احنا نزحنا من ثالث يوم الحرب رحنا
على المدارس انتشرت فيها الاوبئه والامراض
وهيك كثير تعبنا منها فرحنا اضطرينا على
الدير لما قالوا الدير مكان امن رحنا عليه
بعدين صار قصف فوق روؤسنا طلعنا من الدير
رحنا على نصراط في نصراط نزلوا اليهود
مناشير برضه صار قصف فخوف من الامر هذا
كثير اجينا احنا و 21 نفر انا وابويا وامي
واولادي واخوتي ونسوان اخوتي كلنا فاجينا
هنا قالوا على رفح نا ثلاث ايام في رفح زي
ما انتم شايفين في العراء فش شغلات تحمينا
نقص في الاحرامات نقص في يعني حتى شحف
المياه الحلوه المالحه فيش حتى اللي معه
مصاري خلصت ما الناس بطل عندها ما حاولتوا
تشوفوا ماوى تشوفوا خيمه تشوفوا مدرسه
تشوفوا اي مركز اوا المدارس كلها على بكره
ابيها مليانه المدارس مليانه الناس كلها
نصبت خيم كلها زي ما انت شايف في الشوارع
فيش نهائيا متسع اي انسان في المدرسه
فاضطر ان نقعد لنا ثلاث ايام احنا كيف
بتدبر اكل كيف تدبروا بتشربوا بتروح
الحمام ربنا اللي بيعلم بالحال احنا جامع
ف هنا قريب منا ممكن لما الواحد بده يقضي
حاجته بروح على الحمام اللي هنا اما انه
قصه نقص في كل شيء في كل شيء ايش ما تتصور
نقص في كل شيء في الميه الحلوه في الميه
المالحه في الاكل في الشرب الخبز نفسه
يعني حتى رغيف الخبز تكلفته لو الواحد بده
يعجن يعني خمسه شكل بتطلع لي واحن بطل
الواحد ي كيف تحملوا هالاجواء
البارده ربك بعين ايش بدنا نعمل وين نروح
مش عارفه والله وين نروح والله ماني عارفه
الله يعين الكل ويصبر الناس كلها طالما
انت شايف الناس كلها اللي حواليك هيك
تعبانه انت نفس يعني انت عمالك بضوء المر
زي الناس هذ كلها دايقه المر وبدنا نتحمل
كرمال بلدنا وان شاء الله ربنا بيرجعنا
سالمين غانمين يا رب اذا حصره قهر وجع الم
تشرد هكذا هو حال سكان قطاع غزه الذين
يفرون من منطقه الى منطقه هربا من الحرب
هاني الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح